welcome back everyone while we're all
discovering our new normal we're still
trying to keep our kids healthy
and on a schedule whether they're going
back to school virtually or perhaps
going into an actual classroom samantha
vickers shares a
few must-have items to help tackle the
new normal
i am here to share a few things that
hopefully will help
with that transition back to school make
it a little bit easier
now the first thing is um zarby's
naturals i wanted to bring this on
because zarby's naturals children's
complete multivitamin
plus immune gummies are really great way
to help our kids get all of the vitamins
and minerals that they need
into their daily diet zarby's has packed
this with 13
essential vitamins and minerals
including vitamin a
vitamin c d3 they put a total b
complex in here as well as zinc and real
elderberry
extract to help with immune support so
really so many fantastic things for our
kiddos and you can get this locally at
cvs or target
and you can also order it on amazon so
you can go to zarbys.com
and read out more about this and all the
other products that zarby's
offers um as well and so the second
thing that i wanted to share is a really
fun product
um that is created by two teenage
brothers
now this is a mask product yes i know
you
wouldn't think this was a mask but it is
and the way you use it is that you go
ahead and put it
all the way over your head and you wear
it around your neck and then
as you need to you just pull up some of
the fabric over your mouth and your nose
now it's a great product and it's super
super comfy and stretchy
because it's not going to pull on your
ears it doesn't even need to be on your
ears at all because it just goes around
your neck and the mouth and nose
um and so not on your ears it's going to
stay on your neck it's not going to fall
off or get dirty or get lost
and so you know really a fun product
that comes in lots of different colors
and sizes
and you can go to redtractormasks.com to
check this out and to support these
young entrepreneurs
now you know sometimes when we're
wearing our masks our eyes can start to
get dry
and allergy season is right around the
corner too and that can cause dry eyes
also
now via dyes is a company i came across
that has
not only the tear support for dry eyes
and with masks but
they also have another product that i
thought was going to be great for back
to school
and that is their blue light defender
and this
is really really neat because it helps
support your eyes
from the inside out so as we have
teachers and students that are on
devices
you know this is going to be a great way
for them to help with any eye strain
and really support their eyes now this
is for 12 and up and it comes in these
yummy gummies or
capsules and you can get this on amazon
or on their website which is biteise.com
so you know i couldn't forget about our
wonderful teachers and
all the hard work that they put in and
also parents and even
mom friends um with these beautiful care
kits
and so this is a really fantastic
thoughtful gift
that i wanted to share with everyone and
this is from a company called
janecarrerink.com and
they have six different kits that you
can choose from and they all
this is one whole kit you guys so this
has everything in it and lots of goodies
essential oils
you know positive affirmation cards you
know so many fun things
so you can really look and see which of
their six kits
is going to be the best one for you to
give to somebody and what i really love
about
jane care is that not only are you
giving something wonderful to someone
but
jane care is also going to give back to
charity so a great way to feel good
about your purchase